vous avez lu l'infini bon
personnellement je suis un petit peu
déçu parce que ça veut dire que je vais
pas pouvoir parler les deux autres
thèmes mais pas si déçu que cela parce
qu'en fait l'infini si tu es mon thème
préféré parmi les 3 donc je suis
vraiment content que vous ayez lu alors
je vais faire un petit débriefing des
résultats du vote et ça va être assez
intéressant parce qu'il ya pas mal de
choses à dire à la fois sur la théorie
des systèmes de vote et sur les
statistiques à ce sujet est d'ailleurs
en fait peut-être la première fois que
je joue avec un vrai jeu de donner ça
c'est vrai parce que l'étude je fais des
mathématiques théoriquement appliquées
en ce qu'ils recherchent et ça veut dire
que c'est censé pouvoir être appliquées
ou être applicable mais personnellement
j'ai jamais fait l'observation que mais
mathématiques étaient vraiment appliqués
mais avant de parler tout ça je vais
vous parler un petit peu de ma situation
personnelle qui va justifier le fait
qu'ils le rythme de publication des
vidéos va malheureusement diminué dans
les six mois à venir est la raison pour
laquelle ça va diminuer c'est que j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir obtenu un nouveau
job à l'école polytechnique fédérale de
lausanne ces deux là d'où je vous parle
ce n'est pas le fond vert habituel pas
tout ce qu'il faut comme d'habitude que
du coup va me falloir déjà quelques
semaines pourra essayer de mettre
toujours place à nouveau pour essayer de
me remettre dans un rythme et puis
surtout bas maintenant j'ai un job
avant j'avais pas de job du coup je vais
être plus occupés s'est dit j'aimerais
vous parler un petit peu du job que je
commence officiellement aujourd'hui même
si aujourd'hui est un jour férié en
suisse donc plutôt de moins j'imagine
donc je veux reprendre en main un projet
qui s'appelle le wanted a donc c'est un
projet qui a été lancé au sein de
l'école polytechnique fédérale de
lausanne par un ami à moi me dit elle
m'a dit qui a pour but de faire des
vidéos sur des concepts clés en
mathématiques en physique et en
informatique pour des étudiants au
niveau licence
par exemple j'adore la série de vidéos
que mehdi a fait sur les suites de kochi
une à une au site qui est très
intéressante sur la thermodynamique
bon c'est pas des maths c'est forcément
intéressant mais c'est quand même pas
mal aussi
et plus récemment sur un ida il eut
aussi des ruisseaux maurice mener des
résumés
paquet de recherche au niveau recharges
bon ça c'est plus à destination des
chercheurs ou des étudiants au niveau
master qui se fait penser à relancer une
carrière académique et à se lancer dans
une dans une thèse - dida c'est un
projet auquel je crois énormément parce
que je pense que contrairement notamment
aux mook ces grands courts massif ou un
prof va faire tout son cours devant une
caméra et du coup avoir des vidéos
longue d'une heure avec beaucoup de
choses aborder des trucs qui vont à
gauche à droite vous êtes très précis
sur un concept clé du coup c'est
difficile de retrouver les informations
quand on manque là les vidéos de wanted
à charge vraiment à répondre à des
questions que les étudiants se pose et
qu'il tape du coup typiquement sur
google ou sur youtube et je pense que
c'est vraiment une approche beaucoup
plus web beaucoup plus qui correspond
beaucoup plus la manière dont les gens
interagissent vraiment avec le web
donc c'est pour ça que je pense que mon
ida est vraiment un projet qui a de
l'avenir clic et la façon de faire des
vidéos en ligne donc dans ces vidéos
wendy d'agde à la fois des vidéos qui
sont faites par bompard midi à l'époque
et du coup la voir des vidéos qui sont
maintenant faite par mois mais il ya
aussi pas mal de vidéos qui vont en fait
par des profs tellement d'épreuves de
l'apefel mais aussi des profs extérieur
le but étant vraiment de vous mettre au
contact des tous meilleurs professeurs
envie de dire du monde essayait d'avoir
vraiment leurs explications qui sont
seront très très clairs de principes
fondamentaux de d'idées de concepts
importants que vous retrouver dans vos
courriers que vous avez peut-être un peu
de mal à comprendre en lisant un livre
de cours vous avez pu vous pouvez
peut-être à moitié de l'explication qui
vous avait été donné en cours et du coup
ça serait bien d'essayer d'avoir l'autre
moitié nouvelle explication mais c'est
un peu ce que c'est d'apporter aux indes
idée en tout cas sa vision que j'en ai
donc candidat à échéance et en
particulier par le département
d'informatique et de communication de
l'école polytechnique fédérale de
lausanne
du coup les vidéos sont plus axés
informatique mais il ya aussi un peu de
mathématiques et de physique
donc ce qui mènerait pas mal notamment
s'il ya des étudiants parmi vous c'est
que vous me dites il ya ce que vous en
pensez de ces vidéos est ce que ça vous
aide vraiment qu'est ce qui pourrait
améliorer la vidéo selon vous et puis
également essayé de donner une liste de
thèmes dont notamment le commentaire de
cette vidéo de thèmes qui sont
ils sont très approprié how i ended à
saisir typiquement des questions que
vous vous posez pendant le court je
m'adresse plus aux étudiants
d'université du cycle supérieur ou de
prépa typiquement à une vidéo que j'ai
en tête la séparant théorème de rôle qui
est un programme très simple on le lit
mais on prend pas forcément tous puis
notamment l'intuition derrière ce
théorème qui est assez importante je
pense on l'a pas forcément on se sent un
peu éloigné de l'analyse et si on
n'arrive pas à voir une intuition de
cette théorie du coup province autonome
et intégralement partant donc c'est
typiquement le genre de terrain que
j'aimerais aborder dans des vidéos one
bigard ceci étant dit je fais vraiment
la part des choses à au moins dix là
c'est le projet qu'il ya le pfl c'est un
truc qui est beaucoup plus universitaire
beaucoup plus institutionnels notamment
je veux faire intervenir pas mal de
professeurs du coup je mon avis
personnel notamment n'aura rien à faire
là bas ma façon de raconter les choses
aussi va être différente soit ni
d'offres beaucoup plus un mode cours et
je continue bien sûr cnce warhol avec
cette série notamment sur l'infini je
vous redis un petit peu le teaser que
j'avais mis dans le hall forme de la
somme incluse au christ roi fût ce cadre
également un douzième aux paradoxes et
de banhars tarski de l'inexistence de
l'ensemble de tous les ensembles à
l'incomplétude de gödel des doutes sur
la consistance de l'arithmétique à une
alternative moderne de la théorie des
ensembles cette série fut nous fera
douter de vos moindres conviction
mathématiques et de l'existence d'une
vérité objective
c'est vraiment l'objectif est pour
aborder tous là-bas en fait j'ai deux
références majeures à vous recommander
une que vous pourrez tous lire avec vous
devez tous lire un de mes objectifs
c'est que vous finissiez par lire ce
livre à la fin de cette série donc le
livre dont je parlais cissé logicomix
que je viens de relire pour la troisième
fois avant de faire cette vidéo qui est
un livre absolument merveilleux vance et
c'est mon livre préféré tout simplement
je pense de tout ce qu'il ya c'est un
livre c'est une bd qui raconte
l'histoire des fondations des
mathématiques au tournant du siècle donc
à la fin du 19ème siècle au début du 20e
siècle avec des fight entre poincaré
eelv et art une espèce de tram qui lie
logicien et folie
puisque dans l'histoire de la logique
beaucoup de logiciels ont fini par
devenir complètement fou c'est vraiment
une lecture très intéressante et comment
elle est co écrite par une mairie dole
mathématiques ou informatique pour le
coup papadimitriou qui est rarement
croyable de chercheurs en informatique
et la théorique qui a fait qui permet de
papier que je trouve absolument
incroyable vraiment ce bouquin est
vraiment excellent envoyé quelques
passages un peu what the fuck you ils
essaient de de raconter eux mêmes en
train d'éclore le vosgien que moi
personnellement je trouve super
intéressant mais bon c'est parce que
comme je suis je vais faire beaucoup de
vidéos j'ai séparé de vulgariser aussi
du coup je trouve ça intéressant de voir
la manière dont je réfléchisse à la
vulgarisation mais c'est vrai que pour
le lecteur qui s'intéresse
essentiellement aux mathématiques se
passe à lula sont assez froide de fuck
et l'autre livre dont j'ai bien sûr
oublier de parler quand je me suis
enregistré c'est un livre sur la théorie
aux motos pic des types qui est un des
livres les plus incroyables que j'ai
jamais lu qui a été coécrit par mon
groupe
or d'une 20 30 voire quarantaine de
chercheurs mathématicien un institut à 2
2 va être in-stat 10 à princeton et qui
essayent de refonder tout simplement les
mathématiques à partir de nouvelles
fondations et d'un nouvel axiome qui
s'appelle l'action d'uni valence
vraiment un livre fantastique tout cas
on va parler pas assez à mon goût mais
on va finir pas en parler donc j'espère
que vous êtes vraiment excité à l'idée
de parler de l'infini et notamment des
fondations mathématiques et des raisons
pour lesquelles d'infini c'est vraiment
vraiment très difficile et très délicat
être très intéressant et très est très
très fécond qui a été donné lieu à
énormément de très belles mathématiques
maintenant je veux en venir a commenté
un peu les résultats du vote
et comment est ce que j'ai fait pour en
venir à la conclusion que vous avez élu
l'infini par rapport par opposition aux
deux autres thèmes que vous proposez qui
étaient les nombres et la théorie les
jeux on peut commencer par jeter un coup
d'oeil à ce que nous donne
de forme google forme nous donne donc la
liste des notes pour chacun des thèmes
avec le nom à chaque fois la fréquence à
laquelle chacune des notes a été donné
pour tel ou tel thème donc par exemple
pour l'infini et des fondations des
thématiques
il y en a cent soixante-quatorze parmi
vous donc plus de 45% qui ont voté dix
sur dix pour l'infini les fondations la
thématique 12 % parmi vous un peu plus
de 12% qui ont mis 9 sur 10 donc on voit
que les fondations d'un fini fondation
mathématiques a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de bonnes notes
il y en a quatorze autres pour cent et
qui ont mis 54 et puis assez peu
derrière alors que son regard d'arrêter
ou des jeux on voit que le graff est
beaucoup plus distribués et a même pas
mal qui ont mis 4 qui ont mis 10 sur 10
23% termine donc plus une personne sur
cinq
parce qu'une personne sur quatre mais on
a aussi beaucoup parmi vous qui ont mis
un sur dix à la théorie des jeux
visiblement la fario qui ne voulaient
pas en entendre parler
on regarde les nombres et les on voit ça
ressemble pas mal plus à l'infini et les
fondations mathématiques il ya quand
même pas mal parmi vous de 35% qui ont
mis 10 sur 10 mai donc moi quand même
que l'infini et puis j'avais plus
distribués aux notes entre 5 et 7 et 8
par rapport à ce qu'on est ce que vous
avez fait pour l'infini donc quand on
voit la lueur des notes on a envie de
dire que quand même préféré l'infini
sauf que m'ont parlé d'ailleurs comme ça
c'est pas très mathématique et il nous
faut un critère pour choisir l'un de ces
trois est un critère pour choisir l'un
de ces trois bassins typiquement un
système de vote dans le genre de chose
dont je vous aurais parlé si on avait
parlé de théorie des jeux mais comme
vous n'avez pas choisi de parler du
terrible et je pense que je vais faire
un rapide topo sur les systèmes de vote
dont les scrutins en général dans le
monde entier
il n'existe pas énormément en gros on
peut dire qu'il en existe et 3 on va
dire le premier c'est le système à un
tour donc c'est celui qui pratiquait
notamment aux états unis où il ya autant
de candidats qu'on veut et que chacun
vote pour un seul candidat et puis le
candidat qui est lui gagne les élections
et ça ça c'est lieu dans pas mal de pays
au monde ait eu des pays où le vainqueur
de l'élection s'est retrouvé avec
seulement 25% des voix
donc j'ai pas du tout les trucs en tête
mais alors je vais faire une
intervention sur ed bangs
le son est mauvais mais vous pouvez
regarder les slides où je parle un peu
quand je donne des exemples philippines
où là quelqu'un avait été élu président
des philippines avec un peu plus de 20%
seulement des votes
et ça ce pas terrible parce que 20%
c'est à dire qu'elle aime presque
quatre personnes sur cinq qui n'a pas
voté pour ce candidat quoi si on essaie
de transposer ces à la france et c'est
quasiment enfin marine le pen pour être
quasiment être élu avec l'enfant cent
des votes
donc ça c'est une preuve d'un premier
argument pour dire que le système un
tour est pas bon en fait je pense que
c'est pas le
la raison principale pour laquelle
scrutin est pas bon le raison principale
c'est que le scrutin soit en fait si on
lui donne un peu de temps on se rend
compte qu'ils manient mais luc ta ble
ment un bipartisme donc une super vidéo
de sites jpy gré à ce sujet
spécifiquement si vous voyez les états
unis mais il ya vraiment que deux
parties bon aujourd'hui
son but pour des raisons d'ailleurs sont
liés à l'utilisation du web des
personnalisations de facebook et de
google des sources d'information les le
bipolarisme américain est incroyablement
ex 38 aujourd'hui mais on le retrouve un
peu ailleurs aussi en français il ya
encore de gros party on sait que début
d'une élection certains de ces deux gros
party qui va être élu et ça restreint
énormément le débat politique
si on essayait d'y réfléchir un petit
peu quand il n'y a que deux vrais
candidats en vrai qu'on les sorte à ce
moment là pour gagner on se rend compte
qu il suffit tout à coup d'être juste
préféré à d'autres personnes et du coup
il suffit de dire que l'autre personne
est mauvaise du coup on a un système de
politique à la baisse qui se crée
naturellement et du coup presque tenté
de dire
le théoricien au des jeux en moi j'ai
fait la théorie des jeux en tête
notamment a envie de dire que l'on fait
le choix du scrutin de vote et en partie
la cause du bipolarisme extrêmement
prononcée peut-être de la faiblesse de
la variété des propositions politiques
que l'on trouve sur la scène politique
c'est sans doute pas la seule raison et
puis j'aurais pu en débattre bien plus
si vous avez choisi de parler la théorie
des jeux mais je pense que c'est ça
contribue quand même donc ça c'est lé
scrutin tout ce côté 1 2 tours comme on
l'a vu en reste lui qui existent en
france en fait il a les mêmes défauts
peut-être l'illusion qu'ils aient plus
de parties en france mais au final quand
vient l'heure de vérité il n'y a
toujours que deux parties et puis après
il ya le truc un peu extrême inverse qui
est le scrutin à la proportionnelle mais
c'est un peu un nombre x en fait la
proportionnelle c'est à dire que si on
voulait voter vraiment une décision
la proportionnelle ne suffit pas en fait
la preuve par semaine ça serait juste
une étape intermédiaire et après il y
aurait ces histoires internes en si le
parlement est très divisée comme ça a pu
être le cas en angleterre ou en
allemagne à une certaine époque il va
falloir chercher des coalitions et du
coup il ya un jeu poétique qui va
décider de l'adhésion au final et alors
est ce que ça c'est bien ou mal je sais
pas je peux pas m'avancer sur ça mais on
sent que c'est moins démocratique que
c'est plus après une histoire d'hommes
politiques qui va faire la décision
finale
bref les scrutins qui existent
aujourd'hui sont à mon sens très
imparfait et du coup on peut se demander
ce qu'est une bonne façon de faire mieux
l'historique mango a lieu un débat au
xviiie siècle avant que de nous fasse il
existe en france entre condorcet et de
borda où les deux je pense que vous
voyez bien plus loin que ce qui est
utilisé aujourd'hui et en gros dans les
deux cas on peut remarquer que le
une solution pour aller au delà des
systèmes qui existent aujourd'hui c'est
de donner plus de droits de parole au
peuple en un certain sens c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui lorsque l'on vote contre
choisy qu'un seul candidat qu est-ce qui
a ses limites en est à ce que propose
condorcet et de bordas et d'aller un peu
plus loin de permettre un droit
d'expression plus grands sur les
différentes options et ça c'est
typiquement ce que j'ai mis en place
dans le google forme que vous avez
rempli ou au lieu de dire un des choix
de sélectionner un des choix je vous ai
dit de noter les choix donc ça c'est un
système à deux bordas vous pourrez y
lire la personne on va mettre des notes
et puis de borda 10 est bon à prendre la
moyenne et voilà ça va élire la personne
sa personne avec la meilleure moyenne va
être élu ce système de vote c'est celui
qui est utilisé si vous y réfléchissez
dans les concours donc pendant que les
concours aux grandes écoles c'est ce
système de vote où chaque professeur va
être une espèce d'experts qui va donner
une note
et puis après on va faire la moyenne
donc ça fait une moyenne pondérée
peuvent avoir plus de poids que l'homme
enfin certaines matières en fait tu peux
avoir plus de prêts que d'autres et puis
après on sélectionne on choisit le
candidat qui a la meilleure moyenne et
donc ça ce système de vote et de borda
il est bien mais il a quand même pas mal
de défauts notamment si vous y
réfléchissez un petit peu si on prenait
la moyenne vous n'avez pas intérêt à
l'ordre à voter vos vrais préférence
imaginons par exemple que vous préfériez
l'infini au nombre à la théorie des jeux
et que vous sentez que ça va se jouer
entre l'infinie les nombres fait vous
n'avez pas intérêt à mettre 10 9 2 vous
avez intérêt à mettre 10 00 pour ne pas
dire un jeu vous préférez largement
l'infini et de faire en sorte que la
moyenne pour votre influence sur la
valeur moyenne va être aussi exacerbée
que possible pour favoriser autant que
possible l'infini par rapport aux autres
thèmes autrement dit vous n'avez pas
intérêt à voter vos vrais préférence
mais du coup quand moi j'analyse les
résultats les l'amour analyse va être
biaisé par le fait que les données qu'on
m'a donnée sont pas les bonnes et du
coup le résultat du vote final ce qu'il
est légitime à ce moment là vous voyez
le problème que et c'est un vrai
problème et c'est par exemple qu'elle
conversait a énormément critiqué de
borda et récemment il ya eu deux
chercheurs français
michel balinski et rida laraki qui ont
trouvé à mon sens une excellente
variations de ce modèle de ce scrutin à
la de borda ou au lieu de prendre la
moyenne des notes il propose de prendre
la valeur médiane et ça en fait c'est
beaucoup plus robuste à la manipulation
si vous avez beaucoup moins intérêt à
mentir que dans le cas précédent
bon en pratique là dans notre cas ça
changeait pas grand chose puisque la
valeur moyenne des votes et la valeur
médiane était supérieure pour l'infini
par rapport au nombre on peut importe
scrutin qu'on choisisse parmi ces deux
là de toute façon on élit l'infini mais
ça c'est pas le système de vote que j'ai
choisi d'utiliser en fait le système de
vote que j'ai choisi d'utiliser bien
avant que l'on commencé à voter avec
l'ipad lancé
c'est normalement faut annoncer ça avant
mais bon c'est pas grave moi le scrutin
que je voulais mettre en place et celui
de condorcet alors le scrutin de condor
cet équipement ce que vous auriez dû
faire pour le faire vraiment c'est
ordonné en faites vous thème du préféré
au moins préférées à travers les notes
je peux déduire qu'elle aurait été le
classement que vous avez fait parce que
celui auquel vous avez donné à mme
ernotte c'est celui qui se pose que vous
préférez et à partir de ces classements
des thèmes que vous donnez moi je peux
combiner tous ces résultats et savoir si
si je faisais un référendum entre deux
alternatives
la quête de ces alternatives ne
gagnerais nous parlons si je regarde
entre l'infinie et les nombres il y en a
cent cinq parmi vous qui ont dit qu'ils
étaient indifférents très deux femmes
qui ont donné la même note aux deux ânes
à 165 qui ont dit qu'ils préféraient
l'infini au nombre et il y en a cent
quarante deux qui ont dit l'inversé
préférez les nombres à l'infini et du
coup il ya eu plus de gens qui disent
préférer l'infini au nombre que l
inverse
du coup on imagine que s'il y avait un
référendum entre les deux ce sont ceux
qui ont préféré l'infini qui vont gagner
millions 165 contre 142 et de la même
façon si on compare l infini à la
théorie des jeux il y en a 2 145 parmi
vous qui disent préférer l'infini contre
119 qui préfèrent le
je donc l'infini battrait les jeux la
théorie des jeux et puissant est
quelqu'un que j'ai fait de la même façon
les nombres battrait la théorie des jeux
avec un même rapport de contrat donc si
on y réfléchit un petit peu on voit que
l'infini bas n'importe quel autre thème
en référendum est bien pour condorcet un
thème qui satisfait cette propriété est
ce qu'on appelle un vainqueur de
condorcet et donc pour condorcet ce
qu'ils croyaient au concept c'est la
majorité qui doit décider si c'est la
majorité qui décide
selon condorcet ça doit être l'infini
qui doit être alors élu est assez
amusant de se dire que en fait en
pratique lorsqu'on fait un système de
tour ou un tour à tour c'est un peu
difficile de parler de dire mais un
système à deux tours en tout cas en
général aux vainqueurs de condorcet ne
va pas gagner et d'ailleurs lors des
dernières élections présidentielles en
le vainqueur de condorcet était ni
françois hollande ni nicolas sarkozy le
vainqueur de condorcet était françois
bayroux qui battait chacun des deux ans
référendum et pour en savoir plus je
vous invite à lire ce superbe article
sur images des maths de rémy perd quand
même cette série de trois articles qui
est vraiment vraiment excellente
il y aura plus encore à dire mais bon
c'est déjà un très bon parce qu'il écrit
et puis une histoire c'est marrant tu
que je vous raconterai sans doute un
jour surtout si on vient pas exact et
les jeux et de ma propre pression entre
condorcet remy père et moi parce que
légalement je pense qu'il faut appliquer
le système de combat recel mais
malheureusement il y avait son appel des
paradoxe de condorcet qu'ils rendent des
trucs un peu compliqué il vous faut
trouver une solution de contourner le
problème et notamment cours de mes
recherches je tombais sur un truc assez
jolie kim à la coupe pas mal convaincu
qu'il ya un scrutin à utiliser qui est
le meilleur scrutin de tous et cela dit
en passant ce scrutin peut être utilisé
pour il ya en prenant tout et n'importe
quoi si vous voulez passer une soirée
entre amis
les choisir le film que vous allez voir
où le resto vous allez aller où le bar
une décision de groupe qui doivent être
faites
sa décision de groupe doit être faite à
l'aide d'un système de vote qui est
généralement un système un peu bâtard
gens rien mais qu'il dessine parmi les
autres suivent
mais il ya moyen de rendre la chose plus
démocratique et je me suis dit depuis
plus d'un an que j'écrive une
application pour smartphone qui fassent
cela malheureusement j'ai jamais eu le
temps de les développer
donc j'espère que ce message n'est pas
tombé dans l'oreille d'un sourd s'il ya
quelqu'un parmi vous qui a des talents
de développeurs et qui veut se lancer
dans l'écriture de cette app
ben je suis prêt à travailler avec vous
je créais pas forcément énormément de
code moi même mais enfin je suis prêt à
contribuer ce qui est ce qu'il faut pour
voir une app sur les scrutins sortir et
peut-être qu'à force d'utiliser cette
app un jour on n'utiliserait même
inscrite en intelligent pour élire des
présidents de la république
dernière question que j'aimerais poser
c'est est-ce que vous préférez vraiment
l'infini au nombre est ce que la
différence que j'observe qu'une
différence de 20 voix seulement parce
que c'est une différence qui est
vraiment significative ou est ce que
c'est juste le fruit du hasard que s'ils
ont relancé le vote
bon on aura peut-être un autre résultat
avant même de rentrer nos statistiques
faut dire qu'il ya peut-être des biens
qui sont signés notamment la manière
dont j'ai présenté
le vote si vous regardez la page avec
les questions vous voyez que le premier
lot de pages c'était mon truc préféré et
ses leaders hasard que j'ai commencé par
me préférait et que peut-être que ça va
plus vous influencer brajeux à côté de
ça pour ajouter la manière dont j'écris
et descriptifs je pense avoir quelqu'un
à ses vendeurs pour chacun des trois
mais oublions un peu ces billets qui
sont vraiment difficile à analyser
et si on se de se demander est ce que si
je relançais ce vote tel quel
aujourd'hui est ce que j'aurai le même
résultat ou est-ce que s'il y avait au
lieu de 400 personnes qui ont beau
d'essai la4 soins qui fait beaucoup
plaisir qui est né au temps mais j'ai
donc être une personne qui a jeté un
million de personnes qui votent
est ce que les résultats seraient les
mêmes alors la manière classique de
répondre à cette question c'est en
utilisant une méthode qui s'appelle la
méthode de la paix va lui qui est la
méthode plus standards de toutes les
sciences et la plus la plus importante à
comprendre si on veut pas tomber dans
des erreurs statistiques lorsque l'on
fait des sciences lorsqu'on est
notamment l'un scientifique d'entre eux
qu'à une façon appliquée cette méthode
de la paix va lui consiste à partir de
l'hypothèse selon laquelle en face non
vous imaginez que vous préférez vraiment
les nombres à l'infini ou plutôt on va
dire que vous préférez autant les
nombres à l'infini imaginons que vous
êtes 50/50 vraiment 50 50 entre
l'infinie les nombres est ce que les
résultats qu'on a obtenus sont des
résultats auxquels on peut vraiment
s'attendre quand je la dis ça je suis
content que si jamais les résultats
qu'on obtient son incompatible avec
l'hypothèse sur laquelle vous préférez
en fait autant en l'infini et les
nombres ce que vous allez dire que
l'hypothèse sur laquelle vous préférez
autant l'infini nombre est en fait assez
un plausible au vu des résultats et que
du coup il faut la rejeter et conclure
qui en fait il vous avez vraiment une
préférence et que du coup cette
préférence est forcément l'infini au
nombre donc je vais voir si je peux
rejeté l'hypothèse selon laquelle vous
préférez en fait autant l'infini au
nombre c'est comme ça que marche
la philosophie du capot père y est né à
cliquer avec ces méthodes statistiques
de la paix value donc on va oublier les
105 qui ont mis
un différend pour simplifier on va
supposer que les résultats du vote c'est
vraiment 165 contre 142 et que en fait
ces résultats sont été obtenu avec
des gens qui préféraient autant l'infini
au nombre c'est à dire avec des tirages
sont exactement comme des tirages pile
ou face
est ce que en lançant des pièces dont
300 fois environ est ce que il est
probable qu'au bout de trois cents ans
et on tombe dans une situation où il ya
165 piles et 142 face eh bien on peut
répondre à cette question une façon de
c'est vachement simplifier le problème
c'est de supposer que la distribution
que l'on obtient lorsque l'on fait 300
lancer la distribution du nombre de
piles va suivre une courbe gaussienne
donc c'est une approximation qui peut
être justifiée à l'aide de théorème qui
disent que ça fait à peu près ça
notamment théorème centrale limite qui
est un des plus beaux hôtels mairies
thématique d'aucune gaussienne c'est une
courbe comme ça et la moyenne de 7 go
ciel ça va être le nombre moyen de piles
que l'on obtient lorsqu'on lance une
pièce 300 x 250 et il va avoir un autre
pari qui va être les quartiers à quel
point la courbe est allé c'était car
type peut être calculé pour un jeu de
pile ou face
donc après un calcul qui passe par la
variance donc la variance de 2 300
lancer ses 300 fois la variance
d'annoncer la variance d'annoncé c'est
un cas ceux qui connaissent les
probabilités je vous laisse leur
démontrer du coup la variance pour 300
ans et ça va être trois cents ans / 4
qui nous fait 75
donc si je veux l'écart type maintenant
il faut prendre racine carrée de 75 qui
est 8 7-6 fumer dans les calculs avec
les braves à voir ce n'est pas 306 307
en fait le diviser par quatre les 8,76
et la moyenne surtout 307 divisé par
deux sa fait 153 points 5
donc non obtenues 165 qui ont voté pour
l'un finit donc 165 pilotes selon ce
modèle 165 c'est
11,5 de plus que la moyenne 2,5 si on
divise sa part 8,76 ça nous fait à peu
près 1,3
c'est à dire qu'on à 1,3 écart type au
dessus de la moyenne dans la gaussienne
donc maintenant on peut aller sur un
site s'appelle mathis fun avec la courbe
normale et donc si on se place à 1,3
écart-type donc c'est le z de leurs deux
aides
on voit que la partie en bleu à
correspond à 10%
donc ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que si je fais un jeu de pile ou face
je tire sur 300 x 300 cette fois à pile
ou face
la probabilité que j'obtiens un résultat
comme celui que j'ai obtenues ou plus
extrême que ce que j'ai obtenu est une
priorité qui est inférieur à 10%
cette valeur qui est dans notre cas 9 7%
est ce qu'on appelle la paix valliot et
donc en sciences on a coutume de dire
qu'un résultat avec statistiquement
significatif si on a une plus value qui
va être inférieure à 5%
autrement dit là notre étude statistique
ne passent pas la barrière classique de
paix va lui et ça ça veut dire que selon
la norme classique de des sciences
notamment je pense aux sciences plus
molle plus sciences sociales notre étude
ici ne passent pas la barrière des 100
sociale selon le critère des sciences
sociales
on ne peut pas conclure au vu des
résultats de ce vote que vous préférez
vraiment l'infini au nom et en
particulier je ne peux rien publier deux
scientifiques
au vu des résultats des données que vous
m'avez donné il y aurait énormément plus
de choses à dire sur ces méthodes a
prévalu moi personnellement je suis le
premier à critiquer cette méthode a
prévalu que je trouve plus généralement
m la méthode scientifique et j'en ai
d'ailleurs parlé dans une conférence que
j'ai donné
au csp à villejuif le centre d'études en
épidémiologie en santé des populations
quelque chose comme ça vous invite à
aller voir cette vidéo parle un peu des
statistiques et la manière dont elles
sont repensés par les statisticiens
d'aujourd'hui voilà j'espère que vous
êtes content du résultat du vote que ça
va quand même l'infini l'allemand ça va
pas trop vous décevoir et j'espère que
vous avez aimé cette petite discussion
sur mon actualité est donc ce job pour
wendy là je mets un lien ici avec qui je
vais être maintenant enlever le patron
sur la théorie des systèmes de vote qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur
puisque c'est un point sur lequel j'ai
travaillé chez la recherche et enfin sur
la paix value qui est un petit méthodes
scientifiques classiques qui a
énormément de défauts mais qu'il faut
avoir appris the quand on essaie de
comprendre ce qui se passe dans le monde
des sciences et à prochaine fois on
parle de l'infini on pas tout à fait en
fait on va parler des grands moments